[музыка]
Привет меня зовут Я из Москвы Я с Чикаго
иной с республики Молдова Кишинёв мои
ожидания от поездки следующие первое
конечно - это получить следующую версию
себя и надеюсь подберу что-то новое
что-то важное Да какие-то чит-код просто
пожить без телефона без звонков без
всяких без всякий суеты
этот тип путешествий я называю экстрим
делюкс экстрим должен быть не более 8
часов всё остальное должно быть как в
хорошем отеле Он выехал 8 часов экстрима
потом приехал вкусно поел посидел Мы
пообщались много нового от меня узнал и
пошёл хорошо отдыхать
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
ци самая самое что не нае жизненная
Прокол колеса сейчас вот командой всей
меняем давно не попадали в такую
ситуацию если честно данном батури
собрались Непростые люди все
руководители бизнесмены и к вечеру мы
поймём
раскроется а кому ещ нужно будет
[музыка]
время Всем привет приче С мано Так что
приезжайте в глубоком глубоком лесу
ночью Мы вошли таю глубокую колею
разорвали правое заднее колесо
программа очень даже насыщенная советую
приезжать
сюда не убирай лебёдку не убирай Давай
это где
[музыка]
ребята сейчас было что-то прекрасное мы
поработали и открыли дорогу два дерева
огромных и вот такой Вот
ножовок Но мы справились и готовы
[музыка]
кушать проснулся в палатке вообще не
поверил где как бы такое вчерашний день
был такой непростым но вот сейчас нырнул
в реку ище всё смыло все сложности
всё супер всё супер плас поэтому сейчас
пойдём и всех остальных поднимем и
попробуем
[музыка]
заманить мы сейчас едем на сплав по реке
Бухтарма мы в этом году решили
совместить баги тур со сплавом потому
что сплав - это То от чего я сильно
Кайфую я хочу чтобы ребята тоже кайфа
вот сейчас едем туда нас там ждут 80 км
точ выб и оттуда мы по этой реке
Бухтарме Прим
сюда Вчера у нас была грязь Сегодня у
нас Вода вот рафтинг лучшее место в
лучшей компании эмоции будут чуть позже
вот там где порог а сейчас мы просто в
боевой
готовности уже
[музыка]
еле прошли не знаю как живыми остались
ребята полетали если несла за которые мы
хвались А так всё нормально выжили всё
нормально все Остались
[музыка]
лодки было много экшена вот а сейчас так
философствующий
и вть все ценности жизни этим бы хотел
сейчас
[музыка]
насладиться вот такой формат это то к
чему Мы стремимся и всё время шлифуем
шлифуем шлифуем и совершенствуем мне
нравится такие пушей суп или бульон
который
получа Обязательно должна быть эстетика
Это мощный экстрим это хорошая команда С
кем ты это делаешь Меня дравит именно
совокупность этого всего это то что
можно получить именно на таких Баги
турах и больше
[музыка]
нигде мы стали друг другу помогать во
всм Мы работаем только командой
а все думают друг о друге Как
[музыка]
семья мы рубили деревя ли мы делились с
последними
конфетами мы ремонтировали это всё
сильно объединяет людей люди
превращается в команду мне интересно
наблюдать как группа 20 разрозненных
людей постепенно превращается в единую
команду и уже действует как слаженный
организм Ну катарага не только
уникальное место Восточного Казахстан Я
считаю оно и потому что здесь
действительно на таком небольшом можно
сказать протяжённость одном районе
сосредоточено очень много
достопримечатель таких мест и это
жемчужна это Южный Алтай здесь наиболее
живописный лёт даже в самом самом Алтае
если так одним словом то это невероятная
Свобода это такие просторы они
безгранично тут такая природа как в
фильмах показывается как вот в
компьютерных играх вот даже не сравнить
фотографии не передают ничего не
передаёт я уже посмотрел в фотоаппарате
не так всё ну как бы надо смотреть в
[музыка]
живую побор самих себя и того чем вы
занимаетесь Когда вы
пересматривает вою миссию своё видение
пересматривать свою целевую аудиторию
ключевые ценности и так далее
пересматривать это не значит что
отказываетесь а пере
подтверждаете всегда оставляю допущение
даже когда строят бетонные мосты всегда
оставляют на расширение материалов
Потому что когда холодно материал
сжимается когда жарко он расширяется
когда ветер дует они играют это должны
детали играть между собой Вот это и есть
эффективное несовершенство потому что
идеально оно бы вообще тютельку в
тютельку
[музыка]
подогнать нужно всё переосмыслить если
честно
много давления на голову мозг работал
активно плюс Свобода Свобода Чувствуй
себя свободной Ну мне очень нравится вот
это
сочетание какого-то обучения плюс вот
этот экстрим О инсайтов вот я сегодня
посчитал их порядка П И ещё не вечер Мы
там ещё сидим Разбираем выделю самое
главное Вот оно сразу будет внедрено
когда вернусь а остальное там уже ПП
Я уже принял для себя определённое
решение которые по приезду обязательно
буду воплощать в жизнь на самом деле
жизнь у меня поменялось ещё с прошлой
поездки а в этот раз я приехал а чтобы
отдохнуть на самом деле вместе с
прекрасными людьми вместе с маглам
калечим и прекрасно провожу время я
очень редко применял слово круто дорого
богато но я хочу сказать ребята здесь
реально круто алтайских горах реально
круто у нас крутое место есть в
Казахстане их много но один из
прекрасных мест - Это Алтайские горы мы
прямо наслаждались тем теми трудностями
которые у нас были и с которыми нам у
нас получалось справляться Это было
очень
круто это стоит тех денег которые мы
оплачиваем за этот тур Я бы советовал
ребятам съездить пообщаться с маргула
калим у которого не голова а Дом Советов
поэтому
[музыка]
Попробуйте Я попытался насытить это Бар
контентом насколько
возможно ребятам вроде
нравится Мне вообще
ба вобще базово Советую всем
путешествовать больше потому
не знаем свою страны Но на самом деле
настоящее путешествие - это когда ты на
баге на мотоцикле на джипе на лошадях и
на природе Вот это путешествие и оно не
просто путешествие оно познавательное и
даёт покой душе
[музыка]
басанов чичу
ценить жизнь ценить каждый день
поскольку время нам не под контрольно
оно постояно у и живите сегодняшним днём
потому что будущее скрыто в любом случае
прошлое уже забыто уже прошло настоящее
даровано поэтому Цените